it's hard to believe it's been more than
25 years since the release of Steven
Spielberg's hook the fantasy adventure
about a middle-aged Peter Pan returning
to Neverland two of the famous grown-ups
in the cast are no longer with us
Hollywood legend Robin Williams is Peter
and British screen and stage star Bob
Hoskins as mr. Smee others including
Julia Roberts is Tinker Bell
Dustin Hoffman is Captain Hook and
Maggie Smith as Wendy are still working
steadily in the spotlight today but what
about the lesser-known members of the
cast what do they look like today Dane
Cappy thoughts because we're about to
find out
Charles Coors moe Jack banning course
both played Peters son Jack who gets
abducted by Captain Hook the dastardly
pirate plays on Jack's anger but his
workaholic father and attempts to bond
with the boy to thwart his nemesis
following hook course beau appeared in
only one more film 1998 can hardly wait
as of the making of this video course
Moe is slated to appear in an upcoming
2018 film called chained for life but
has a different day job in acting these
days cours mo is a lawyer an associate
law professor at Case Western Reserve
University
amber Scott Maggie banning Scott played
the adorably precocious daughter of
Peter Pan Maggie banning kidnapped along
with the brother Jack she famously
called her captor out for his bad
behavior she also sang a sauna movie
when you're alone which was nominated
for an Oscar like her on-screen brother
Charles Kors mo Scott chose not to
pursue an acting career following hook
she's had only one other role to date
voice acting credit for a documentary in
1995 Caroline got Oh Moira banning good
all played Moira granddaughter - Wendy
and wife of Peter Moira and Peter argue
about his work conflicting with his role
as a father
later the couple discovers that their
two children have been abducted by
Captain Hook Goodall landed numerous
high-profile roles in television and
film including Schindler's List opposite
Liam Neeson and the Princess Diaries
with Anne Hathaway Isiah Robinson
Pockets Robinson played one of the many
oddly named lost boys who Peter
encounters in Neverland and one famous
scene The Lost Boys don't initially
believe that the middle-aged man before
them is actually Peter Pan Pockets
reaches out to touch his face finally
recognizing him
oh are you are either following hook
robinson booked only one additional
acting credit for a role in the 2005
film dead at the box office
he now works as a singer for the Los
Angeles Opera Jason Fisher eight you may
remember Fischer as the lost boy who
wore a raggedy top hat and helped his
comrades with Peter back into shape
Fischer also starred in two other films
as a child Parenthood and the witches
although his role as ace and hook marked
his last acting credit Fisher reunited
with his Parenthood cast mates not long
ago and shared that he currently lives
in Florida and works as a professional
golf caddie Dante Basco
Rufio everyone remembers the lost boy
with a bad attitude who assumed
leadership over the group after Peter
Pan went away when Peter returns to
Neverland Dante Basco as Rufio isn't
willing to give up his authority at
first but after Peter finally proves
he's regained his memories Rufio
willingly gives up his sword Moscow was
also known for his tear-jerking death
scene thank you since Hook Moscow has
continued to act focusing on voice work
for several animated series and video
games Rashad Hammond thud but Hammond
played the jolly Lost Boy who rolls down
some stairs and Bulls over several
pirates during the battle with Captain
Hook after Peter decides to return to
the real world
he leaves thud but in charge of the
group
[Music]
following hooks he picked up a few more
roles in the 1990s in 2011 he acted in
and directed a low-budget heist flick 24
hours in Las Vegas
James Matty oh don't ask the lost boy
with a smart mouth tweed jacket and a
feather earring dangling from one ear
was known as don't ask
hook Mark James maddio's first acting
role but he never looked back after that
he's continued to act appearing in
dozens of films and television series
sense you may also remember Matty o for
his role in HBO's Band of Brothers
Matty o also appeared in an episode of
the police drama blue blinds and he
slated to star in the boxing biopic Pat
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]
[Applause]
you